una máquina de dulces hace monedas de
chocolates circulares ok circulares el
diámetro diámetro de cada moneda es de
16 milímetros cuál es el área de cada
moneda bueno déjame hacer aquí un
círculo que represente que represente
una moneda de chocolate y lo que nos
dicen es que el diámetro es de 16
milímetros es decir si tomo si tomo un
segmento que vaya de un extremo del
círculo al otro de estos que justo pasan
por el centro entonces la medida la
medida de este segmento es 16 16
milímetros milímetros vale por acá está
el centro de la circunferencia y con
esta información podemos calcular el
área utilizando la fórmula que conocemos
que dice que el área el área de un
círculo es igual a ti por el radio al
cuadrado es igual a ti
multiplicado por el radio en radio
elevado al cuadrado
aquí nos dan el diámetro no el radio
pero es muy fácil calcular el radio a
partir del diámetro porque es
simplemente la mitad si el diámetro es
16 milímetros
entonces el radio es 88 milímetros y
podemos sustituir este ere en esta
fórmula de acá de modo que el área
el área es igual a ti a ti x 8
milímetros al cuadrado por 8 milímetros
elevado al cuadrado eso de ahí sería
igual le voy a poner igual a pi y x 8 al
cuadrado es decir 64 64 x milímetros al
cuadrado o bien milímetros milímetros
milímetros cuadrados vale usualmente vas
a ver esto escrito más bien con el 64
primero es decir como que el área es
igual a 64 64 x pi
por pi milímetros cuadrados milímetros
milímetros cuadrados y esto de aquí ya
sería una respuesta matemática aceptable
recuerda que pie es un número entonces
esto de aquí es un número y por lo tanto
el área ya es un número de milímetros
cuadrados pero algunas veces nos
gustaría pues aproximar esto por si
realmente queremos dar un número
explícito y para eso se utilizan algunas
aproximaciones de pi la aproximación así
más chafa más más sencilla es que pi es
igual a 3.14 y entonces podemos decir
que el área es aproximadamente igual
aproximadamente igual esto es
aproximadamente igual a 64 64 x 3.14
3.14 milímetros cuadrados milímetros
cuadrados y para ver cuánto es esto
déjame sacar la calculadora aquí tenemos
la calculadora tenemos que hacer 60
x 3.14 eso de ahí es 200 puntos 96
entonces una primera una primera
aproximación es que el área el área es
200 puntos 96 200 puntos 96 milímetros
milímetros cuadrados si quisiéramos una
aproximación todavía mejor podemos
utilizar la la función de pi de la
calculadora voy a poner por acá la otra
aproximación entonces vamos a utilizar
la función de pi creo que aquí tengo que
borrar así entonces voy a poner 64 64 x
pi sale aquí nos pone la aproximación
que tiene grabada y eso es igual a 200
1.06 lo voy a cortar hasta aquí igual es
una aproximación entonces la
aproximación que da la calculadora con
el valor interno que tiene de ti es 200
1.06 vale
entonces el área es aproximadamente
igual a 201 200 1.0
06 milímetros
milímetros cuadrados vale de todas
formas cualquiera de estas dos es una
aproximación y bueno es a lo mejor a lo
mejor que podemos apuntar porque pi y
justo justo sigue y sigue vale no hay un
valor exacto para ti en donde podamos
cortar para dar un valor exacto en
decimales para el área